der Hypnose Sneaker und Mode scheint in
den letzten Jahren immer krasser zu
werden die Stückzahlen reichen nie um
die gesamte Nachfrage zu decken und so
entstehen grau Marktpreise jenseits von
gut und böse aber was macht einen
normalen Sneaker zu einem sehr gehypten
Sneaker ist es möglich darauf Profit zu
schlagen und wie schwer ist das Ganze
lasst es uns gemeinsam herausfinden
[Musik]
hallo Freunde herzlich willkommen zurück
zum Rolex trade ab Projekt eurem
Lieblingsprojekt auf ganz Youtube
Deutschland mein Lieblingsprojekt in den
letzten Videos haben wir zuerst eine
Saturn Mystery Box gekauft mit der wir
uns von 800 Euro auf 1.575 hoch
gehandelt haben dann mit gehebelten
Aktien von 1575 auf
2600 irgendwas - Steuern dann haben wir
aber Leute in die Kommentare geschrieben
dass ich ein Freistellungsauftrag
beantragen kann das bedeutet ich muss
auf 800 und 1 € capital gewinnen keine
Steuern zahlen das bedeutet wir sind
irgendwo bei 2500 € unendlich viele
Leute haben in die Kommentare der
letzten Videos geschrieben dass ich doch
sneakery sein soll genau das machen wir
in diesem Video wenn ihr weitere
Vorschläge habt was wir in den nächsten
Folgen machen können dann lassen wir das
in den Kommentaren stehen und dann
probiere ich das zu machen und bevor ihr
wieder alle in den Kommentaren fragt
welche App ich benutzt habe ich benutze
Hit movement no no product Placement
oder so das ist einfach die App über die
ich die Benachrichtigungen bekomme wann
welche Schuhe online gehen und ich weiß
dass es wieder die meisten Kommentare
sagen werden also ist the way to go für
mich in diesem Projekt es stehen in den
nächsten Wochen unendlich viele Releases
an die vielversprechend sind mit denen
wir möglicherweise viel Geld machen
können wenn wir dran kommen ich habe
mich mit Leuten zusammengetan die uns
erklären können wie Sie Geld mit
reselling machen es wird also ein
geisteskrankes Video bleibt bis zum Ende
dran lass dem Video ein Like da wenn es
euch gefällt und jetzt viel Spaß ich
schaue jetzt wie ich am besten an die
Schuhe ran kommen kann was sind die
besten Taktiken um in der Nike Sneakers
App die Schuhe zu bekommen was ist die
beste Taktik um bei Raffles zu gewinnen
und wie macht man das eigentlich
wie viel lange willst du mitnehmen von
dem Ganzen also ich glaube ehrlich dass
dieses Video nicht so krass viel
einspielen wird wie wie andere weil
weniger Risiko schwerer an die Schuhe
dran zu kommen wenn ich nicht im raffle
Gewinne muss ich die Schuhe quasi schon
auf dem Graumarkt kaufen und dann auf
dem Graumarkt wieder verkaufen also ich
glaube dieses Video wird richtig schwer
aber ich hole mir Tipps von Leuten die
wirklich Ahnung haben ich nehme mir zwei
Wochen Zeit weil ich glaube das eine
Woche halt einfach nicht reicht so über
die zwei Wochen habe ich deutlich mehr
releases in der zweiten Woche kommt zum
Beispiel du sie er Force Jordan 1 Mokka
also da kommen wirklich wirklich noch
Schuhe die die glaube ich richtig was
bringen deswegen mache ich das ganze
über zwei Wochen ihr müsst eine Woche
ohne Rolex Trader Video auskommen aber
es kommen wirklich unendlich viele
Schuhe und endlich viele Möglichkeiten
Schuhe zu bekommen die Profit machen und
genau darum kümmere ich mich jetzt das
Problem ich habe gestern direkt stabile
Releases verpasst also an dem Tag wo ich
die Aktien verkauft habe ist gestern
stabiler Dank und so macht aber nichts
den nächsten Tagen kommen genauso krasse
Releases ich kümmere mich jetzt drum in
möglichst viele Raffles für die für die
nächsten Release das einzutragen und
vielleicht sogar an Schuhe auf dem
gaumenmarkt zu kommen die ich jetzt
gestern oder so nicht bekommen habe
möglicherweise gibt's ja Leute die mir
die für einen guten Preis geben so dass
ich sie trotzdem noch für mehr verkaufen
kann lasst uns wieder eine Menge Glück
haben und eine Menge Geld verdienen
morgen kommt folgender Schuh für diesen
Schuh trage ich mich jetzt in alle
möglichen movement alle aufgelistet also
ich kann einfach alle einzeln anklicken
mich dann überall eintragen das ist aber
tatsächlich echt ein bisschen Arbeit das
werde ich jetzt machen und
möglicherweise haben wir Glück oh mein
Gott damit nur rechnen das erste in dem
ich in diesem Projekt mitmache ist ein
Win mittlerweile kann ich verstehen dass
mir einige Leute nicht mehr glauben
würden dass dieses Projekt Realist
deswegen bin jetzt gerade auf dem Weg
nach Düsseldorf um dort den Schuh im
Laden abzuholen ich habe gerade eben
extra bei Fuster angerufen und gesagt
dass sie mir den bitte nicht liefern
sollen einfach nur damit ich euch zeigen
kann dass das alles real ist und ich den
wirklich im Riffel bekommen habe Kuss
Kuss Kuss an Hit movement no joke alle
Raffles aufgelistet und es hat einfach
direkt geklappt es ist wirklich
unglaublich ich fahre jetzt dahin hole
den Schuh ab und probiere den dann so
schnell wie es geht zu verkaufen
[Musik]
absoluter Traum ich würde den Halt no
Drop direkt selber tragen aber
für diese Projekt muss er geopfert
werden leider habe ich den Schuh auch
ein bisschen überschätzt und tatsächlich
ist der relativ häufig rausgekommen also
viele Leute hatten die Möglichkeit den
zu kaufen was sich natürlich im
Verkaufspreis widerspiegelt hier aber
noch mal die fu-rechnung damit ihr wisst
dass das wirklich alles mit rechten
Dingen zugeht mal sehen was wir für
diesen Schuh bekommen können ich melde
mich ganz kurz mit einer wichtigen Sache
aus dem Schnitt wir haben 2:30 Uhr
nachts einen Tag vor Release ich bin
immer noch am schneiden es war wieder
eine Menge Aufwand wenn ihr mich also
supporten wollt und mir vielleicht dabei
helfen wollt dieses Jahr noch auf
200.000 Abonnenten zu kommen dann
vergesst nicht den Kanal kostenlos zu
abonnieren damit ihr kein Video mehr
verpasst eigentlich waren 100.000
Abonnenten die ist ja mein Ziel jetzt
sind wir aber so kurz vor dem 200.000
ich würde mich sehr freuen jetzt viel
Spaß mit Erklärung wie man an die
Sneakern kommt und was für verschiedene
Methoden gibt der Sneaker mag das
absolut durch die Decke gegangen und
einen multimilladengeschäft gefühlt hat
es sich in vielen Fällen stark vom Sport
weg bewegt woher die verschiedenen
Modelle ja eigentlich kommen hin zu Mode
kamen immer mehr Collaps mit Designern
oder Musikern auch in der Woche in der
ich jetzt trade wird ein Schuh mit Jay
Baldwin kommen und vermutlich preismäßig
auf dem Baumarkt komplett durch die
Decke gehen natürlich hier mit
künstlicher Verknappung gearbeitet es
wäre kein Problem für Nike die Schuhe
einfach in höherer Stückzahl
rauszubringen aber es würde natürlich
weniger reizen diesen dann zu besitzen
grundsätzlich gibt es aber auch noch zu
wissen wie die meisten Sneaker auf den
Markt kommen wie Sie also einfach
verkauft werden raffels die einzelnen
Händler veröffentlichen Listen in die
man sich mit all seinen Daten einträgt
möglich ist es noch dass man ihnen bei
Instagram folgen oder irgendein Beitrag
liken muss dann läuft das Ganze wie ein
Gewinnspiel ab es gibt 100 Paar Schuhe
15.000 Leute wollen sie aber haben das
bedeutet es bekommt nur jeder 150 ein
das verrückte man nimmt nicht an einem
Gewinnspiel teil um den Schuh kostenlos
zu bekommen sondern um eine Möglichkeit
zu haben den Schuh kaufen zu können man
bewirbt sich also auf einen Schuh what
the first come first surf erklärt
sich von selbst der Schuh kommt zu einer
bestimmten Uhrzeit raus und derjenige
der den Schuh als erstes bezahlt bekommt
ihn auch was ist hier aber für Probleme
gibt Stichwort potting erzählt euch
gleich ein Experte Sneakers Sneakers ist
die shop-app von Nike über die quasi die
Release rauskommen und über die man
versuchen kann die Schuhe zu kaufen
meistens gibt es eine Zeit zu der Schule
rauskommt und man hat dann 15 Minuten
Zeit sich wenn sie in ein miniröffel
einzutragen wenn die Zeit abgelaufen ist
bekommt man entweder dieses extrem
befriedigende Popup oder dieses deutlich
häufiger zu sehende deutlich weniger
zufriedenstellende Popup man könnte
meinen dass ich in den letzten Tagen
wieder auf eine absoluten Glück Strähne
unterwegs war dem ist aber nicht so ich
habe in den letzten Tagen wirklich bei
jedem Release mitgemacht also Habibi
dank
Jordan 1 Jay Baldwin war City Maze ich
habe keinen einzigen Sneaker bekommen
und ich brauche einen neuen Plan ich
habe also ein bisschen recherchiert was
gibt's für Möglichkeiten wie kann ich
meine Chance erhöhen als erstes habe ich
gefunden dass man in der Sneakers App
aktiv sein sollte das Nike merkt dass
man nicht nur darauf aus ist die Sneaker
bei Release zu bekommen sondern dass man
sich wirklich dafür interessiert also
habe ich super viele Sachen geliked
außerdem war ein Tipp den Account auf
weiblich umzustellen weil keine Ahnung
warum habe ich auf jeden Fall irgendwo
gelesen dass es helfen soll und
wahrscheinlich der krasseste Tipp den
ich jetzt befolgen und einrichten werde
sind einfach mehrere Accounts ich nehme
paypal-adressen von Freunden und Familie
Lieferadresse von Freunden und Familie
und trage mich in jedes Release mit
mehreren Accounts ich weiß noch nicht
wie viele ich schaffe aber ich würde
hoffen so vier oder fünf das würde meine
Chancen für vier oder fünffachen und ich
hoffe dass es so klappen kann gerade
sieht aber wirklich so aus als wäre das
das am wenigsten erfolgreichste Projekt
von allen aus dieser Serie tatsächlich
habe ich in den letzten Tagen aber nicht
nur Pech gehabt die Jungs von HIT Move
und haben mir diesen classic hier
zugeschickt ich habe noch nie selber
einen Air Force 1 in Weiß besessen
dieser Schuh ist momentan obwohl es ein
Classic ist super schwer zu bekommen und
die Jungs von movement hatten neulich so
ganz hell für den Schuh drin den gab es
für 77 € bei HIT movement absoluter
Traum ist jetzt schon wieder ein
bisschen Zeit vergangen es ist draußen
dunkel geworden und ich habe mir ein
paar Gedanken gemacht und wirklich
Schiss bekommen dass ich auch von den
kommenden Releases keine Schuhe mehr
bekomme was richtig scheiße werden wie
kann ich sicher gehen dass ich noch ein
paar Euro mit Schuhen machen kann habe
deswegen ein bisschen rum telefoniert
ich habe natürlich viele Leute um mich
rum die auch im Sneaker Thema drin sind
und habe deswegen einen Kumpel gefunden
der mir ein paar Schuhe abgeben kann in
den letzten Wochen sind einige Danks
rausgekommen die jetzt nicht super krass
im resell sind und auf denen der jetzt
quasi so ein bisschen sitzen bleibt und
breit ist mir die einfach alle zusammen
für ein vernünftigen Paketpreis zu geben
ich fahre jetzt dahin schaue mir die an
und was das für Schuhe sind seht ihr
nach dem Interview mit Butter bei Nova
einem der größten Sneaker bottigen
Youtuber wenn ihr das Video in
ungeschnittener Form und voller Länge
sehen wollt dann schaut auf meinem
zweitkanal vorbei oder in dem Link in
der Videobeschreibung da beantworten wir
Fragen wie wie kommt man an einen Bot
oder welche Webseiten kann man botten
welche nicht dieses Interview ist
geschnitten und manche Aussagen sind
nicht in voller Länge zu hören also
guckt euch das komplette Interview an
wer bist du und was machst du so mein
Name ist Nova einmal for time counting
Creator talking aboutding in reselling
sneakers and the mir that basiert mein
Soul
it Hawaii everything the all that take
the money 3 Lösungen
Youtube kannst du kurz erklären was
potting eigentlich ist bzw was ist es
nicht ist also zum
Sneakers when the happening is this
things Versace
das very quick so in order to help
increase your chances of being about
successful Sneakers will you have to do
is purchased abrated to the armates and
tired process so you will in
profiles possible
glaubst du jeder kann Erfolg mit botten
haben oder braucht man irgendwelche
Kenntnisse
Penning on you lovercraft
wäre es möglich für dich ohne deine
Einnahmen als Creator nur vom botting zu
leben ja edles Passwort bei unlikely is
special if you live
New York
the Rands for something very very small
maybe like
and you had to be really God
of Warcraft
die letzte und wahrscheinlich meist
gestellte Frage aus meiner Community ist
findest du es fair bzw okay zucken
this is comes the down
limited Stuck für die Sneakers maybe
your last and one hundred pure tears
like
[Musik]
vielen vielen Dank auf jeden Fall am
Nova für das Interview ich bin zurück
von der Mediziner verkauft hat wir haben
insgesamt vier Paar gekauft ein davon
ist ein wahr City purple dank in high in
der Größe neuneinhalb und dann nicht
einen nicht zwei sondern dreimal pure
Platinum dank hi Reset Sneaker schon
länger hat die ganzen Paare in
irgendwelchen Raffles oder in der
Sneakers App bekommen ich weiß es nicht
genau findet das Projekt ziemlich nice
und findet das zu aufwendig die Schuhe
mit so wenig Gewinn zu verkaufen hat mir
die deswegen für einen super Preis
überlassen insgesamt habe ich 450 €
bezahlt das ist nur 10 € über retail
also die drei nimmt habe ich zu retail
für 110 € von ihm bekommen und den warte
purple habe ich für ein Zehner mehr
bekommen das ist super gut und damit
können wir auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Profit machen das Projekt ist
tatsächlich größer geworden als ich
dachte ich hoffe jetzt dass die zweite
Woche noch ein bisschen besser läuft als
die erste dass wir alles verkauft
bekommen und dass wir in der zweiten
Woche natürlich mehr Sneaker bekommen
die im resell dann noch mal deutlich
mehr wert sind vergesst nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren wenn ich die Videos
gefallen vielleicht schaffen wir es auf
200.000 noch dieses Jahr das wäre
doppelt so viel wie ich mir eigentlich
als Ziel gesetzt hatte vielen Dank dass
Sie das Video bisschen angeschaut habt
Kuss Kuss Kuss wir sehen uns am Mittwoch